こんにちははじめ社長です東京なんですけどもう東京の同期で変な商品を見つけました
これこれなんで作ったんだろうはい
全部剃ったの情報北防てもこれがすっ太郎ですねこんな感じですだろう君の顔が書いて
ありますつまんで戻すと全部吸い込む
なんでこんなん作ったんだろうなぁ全く意味わかんです遊び方
それぞれがネバネバエグいが続いてってそれをこのすっだろうが全部剃ってくれるって
思ったらしいです
意味不明ですね1水ですか本当に意味がわからない何で作ったんだろうというかどう
いう遊び方がだけど先生わかんないんですけど
2途中になりすぎて買ってしまいましたあけなります
さあかかっましたあーこの項
知ったろーくんですでこれがネバネバいいかな鳥取スライブでしかないんですけど開け
てみましょう
うんスライムでしかないですよこれ
a これを吸っだろうが吸い込んでくれるらしいですねじゃあストロークんてみ
ましょう
いきます
[音楽]
ジェネレーション米会でどうやってるんですねストロークを打ってほっぺた空をきたな
というほっぺダウングニュってって戻すと
ほ飲んでなんでがこうやって数つけて
四季ねぇなぜならこれ前列ってくれないんですけど
大
[音楽]
ねえええこのさ長さんちょっとさエロいやめとけでちょっと多少はスっていけるみたい
なんですけど全く意味がわからんね
なあ機もあの本当はこれで全部剃ってほしいみたいな感じなら多分
分かりオスだろお前のしたいことこういうことだろうとこれでこうやって
落ち込むと
[音楽]
っつー鈴木ある履かないなぁ骨のホンダ子猫使うのかな
この中でいつもオスいいところができるですけどこの先がいけない
全部剃ってみようとれい絶海
[音楽]
おおおおう
をスレーターストローがつい全部せました
終わっ愛と勇気で無事据えました願いうまいこと調整できる人の何でも降ってくる
みたいですねずっ太郎ですねたぶん何でも捨てる気がしますこいつ俺も吸ってくれるの
かな
[音楽]
denpa
a さあちょっと行きたい2ch だったらなんか持っているんじゃないかなと思って
ちょっといろいろ準備してみましたちょっと吸わせてみましょう
まずはローション実際整理可能性あるんだよローションやってみます
いいいいいい
me
こんな気の労組は末たらもうマイ対してもんだよ
物資では映ってください行くぞ5
葉っぱを
を
ブーブーですねえっつ付いて洗顔クリーム行ってみましょうつっにょ結構大きな
ポイントにあると思います捨てて
増井ゲッタースイングでも分やー
おっ
ええええええん
car
[音楽]
me
uh
バッハ